live local now thank you for joining us  I'm John langler for the second time in  less than a year at Clark County School  District staff member has been assaulted  on campus the principal over at Rancho  High School says this particular  incident happened at seven o'clock last  night just outside the main building at  Rancho police are still trying to  identify a suspect this afternoon you'll  remember near the end of the last school  year Metro Police say a teacher at El  Dorado High was attacked sexually  assaulted by a student in a classroom  that case is still being prosecuted now  for the latest on this developing story  and other breaking news don't forget you  have the 8 News Now app available you  can download it on the Google Play Store  and in the Apple App Store